vous avez raison sur un principe qui
doit tous nous rassembler les règles de
respect du confinement doivent
s'appliquer et être contrôlée par tous
de la même façon sur notre territoire
il n'y a pas de quartier dans lequel nos
forces de sécurité de l'intérieur
n'interviendrait pas et je voudrais
profiter de votre question pour mettre
un terme à ce que j'ai pu lire ou
entendre ça n'était pas le sens de votre
question
selon lequel les forces de sécurité
interne aux policiers de gendarmes selon
les territoires n'interviendrait pas
dans les quartiers je ne tiens pas de
statistiques quartier par quartier
mais je vais prendre quelques exemples
marseille marseille où chaque soir nos
services dress 300 procès verbaux pour
infraction aux règles du confinement
dont les deux tiers sont dans les cités
de marseille en seine saint denis au
cours de ces dernières semaines
chaque soir trois opérations sont
coordonnées dans les cités sensibles
avec l'appui de moyens aériens pour
contrôler ce qu'il s'y passe et
globalement ce sont 220 milles contrôle
qui ont eu lieu et 38 à 1038 mille
verbalisation c'est un peu à peu près en
termes de contrôle le double de la
moyenne nationale et donc je voudrais
réaffirmer qu effectivement nous sommes
présents dans les quartiers pour agir et
pour contrôler et pour protéger celles
et ceux qui au fond en ne respectant pas
le confinement se met en risque mais il
est vrai que dans ces quartiers au
moment où nous intervenons il peut
arriver qu'il y ait des provocations
qu'il y ait des atteintes à nos forces
de sécurité des mises en cause de
l'utilisation de différents projectiles
contre nos forces de sécurité ces
dernières nuits vous l'avez rappelé en
particulier depuis samedi soir des
guets-apens ont été organisées et là
encore je vais vous dire que d'abord
nous les condamnons de la façon la plus
ferme et nous réagissons immédiatement
la nuit dernière une quinzaine de faits
se sont déroulés sur le territoire
national douze personnes ont été
interpellées depuis le week-end dernier
ce sont 28 qui ont été interpellés le
seul sénateur mesdames et sénateurs
n'ayant aucun doute nous veillons à
faire en sorte que le confinement soit
respectée partout en france et partout
nos forces de sécurité intérieures sont
mises en cause sont provoquées nous leur
devons protection nous le faisons et
nous devons sanctionné cela de la façon
la plus ferme possible
merci